open innovation and crowdsourcing is all  around you  when you read an article on wikipedia  hundreds if not thousands of people have  contributed to that article  when you use your smartphone whether  that be an apple device or an android  device the underlying software has been  developed by hundreds of thousands of  people working collectively to create  that software and not working for these  companies like apple or google  when you use your computer and you use  the internet the underlying  infrastructure of the internet has been  developed through open innovation  one of the most valuable companies in  the world apple  thinks about open source and open  innovation as key to their success  indeed the top companies around the  world have figured out how to use the  wisdom of the crowd the wisdom of people  distributed around the world to help  them create products and services that  we use on a daily basis